hey you guys just got one of those you  know these little big bags with a dollar  sign on the side of it okay  yep  you're gonna shoot arrows with shotgun  shells attached to them to a bank window  to blow out the glass then you're gonna  shoot a zip line through that window and  you're gonna slide on into the hallway  you're gonna be wearing roller skates so  you can just skate on past the arm  guards who will be shooting at you and  you're gonna hope that they both won't  hit your legs and if they are aiming at  your torso the suit of medieval armor  will deflect the bullets then you're  gonna hope to gather enough speed to  burst through the big bank vault at the  end of the hallway where you're going to  collect the money in a cartoon money bag  well no i'm just an uncle's wines for  christmas and i uh think i'll take my  business elsewhere merry christmas  it's april